et je vous le dis c'est encore ici que
ça va se passer aujourd'hui un bon alors
alors je loue effectivement une villa
pour les besoins d'un tournage
alors cette ville à la louer à villa
montmorency qui est un quartier du 16e
arrondissement de paris
et la villa mitoyenne de celle de la
maison de nicolas sarkozy ces accords ce
tournage c'est un tournage qui suit le
quotidien de cinq influenceurs qui sont
tous majeurs french house exactement qui
sont des célèbres du tanker et il se
trouve que les influenceurs qui je le
rappelle sont majeurs et ont un manager
qui lui aussi est majeur ont organisé
une soirée clandestine de combien de
personnes de 50 personnes
cinquante personnes inscrites à la
personne je vous le dis parce que j'ai
fait un tournoi de la vérité et toute la
vérité
il y avait toutes les adresses dorée
parisienne d'accord j'ai fait un
tournage similaire il ya pas longtemps
dans une très belle maison avec des
rappeuses et avec plein de mecs de
quartier j'ai eu aucun problème il n'y a
eu aucune fait rien aucun débordement
et là pardon mais ils nous ont trahis je
pense qu'il ya erreur sur nicolas
sarkozy je crois que nicolas sarkozy n'a
jamais appelé la police à l'histoire
exactement ça alors c'est quoi
l'histoire pourquoi ça c'est retombé sur
nicolas sarkozy
il ya une soirée avec des gars à côté de
chez lui et c'est devenu nicolas sarkozy
bientôt ça va devenir nicolas sarkozy a
fait une soirée avec cinq ans dans une
semaine s'arrête là je te retrouverai
seront tout à coup ils sont venus me
chercher en train de danser qu'est ce
qui se passe près mois de mai il faut
toujours une bonne occasion pour ce
faire nicolas sarkozy mais c'est
incroyable parce que c'est à côté de
chez lui ils ont dit que c'était lui qui
avait dénoncé
mais dire qu'il faut tout ouvrir ça pour
moi c'est criminel
les réalisations sont pleines monsieur
philippe au temps quand on est en
différé couvrir depuis une riche qu'est
ce que vous voulez qu'on choisisse ans
mais s'intègre que les réanimateurs que
les réanimateurs soit 90 mais attendait
lui un des leurs animateurs situation de
choisir qui vont rénover ou pas monsieur
hamon un regard des randonnées se
regarder ça vous regarde et savez comme
nous en norvège
ouais 60 ans il a fait un rassemblement
comme vous sans masque 1 c'était un
complotiste
il est mort de la commission d'accord
qu'il est vrai que ça va continuer comme
ça c'est bien quel est le calendrier je
sais que vous avez des infos est-ce que
les terrassements rouvrir me met fin mai
début mais qu'est ce qui va se passer
oui
mais nous avons c'est pourquoi vous at
il mis mais vous allez ouvrir scélérat
seulement oui il était d'accord quoi
parce que factuellement c'est pas les
chips et les chiffres de santé publique
france 2 10% des contaminations se font
à l'extérieur d'un bar ilan entre les
mains
à chaque fois je trouve des messages de
même si c'est des méchas demain commence
à pas trop comment ça se fait j'ai vu en
extra la télé c'est moi ou pas tu as
envie de faire une histoire d'amour et
de partir sur l'autoroute de l'amour
sans péage 600 km avec gêna faire 600 km
pourquoi pas alors oui elle est pourquoi
on va on va essayer quand j'ai envie de
leur donner sa chance
ouais mais est-ce que tintin d'amoureuse
de lui non ouais alors je dis jeu mais
oui mais je pourrais mettre non en fait
le problème il est pas là c est ce que
pierre a envie d'aller habiter dans ces
quartiers là mais non aussi bien que
ceux qui y vivent ils ont pas envie de
rester dans ces ghettos
parce que il ya certains immeubles se
sont devenus mes mais c'est cdc des
pourritures certains immeubles sacré des
quartiers pourris ça crée une ambiance
terrible et ça laisse du coup la place
ba au trafic et autres et autres tracy
pour moi la france c'est comme l'équipe
de france c'est ça la france des noirs
des arabes ont eu en benzema il faut
mais quand vois griezmann qui dansent
avec plus bas
parlez à l'isf une fois tranquillement
annick est ce que vient de dire là au
lieu que ce que vous dites sur l'équipe
de france en la can a été racheté en
grande partie par le qatar donc si c'est
simple tube de français présents
en plus de bien des conneries maintenant
par l'équipe de france répondrait aussi
chez l'allié ouais comme et on va mal
engagée toi aussi bien te fais vacciner
[Musique]
eiser pas
[Applaudissements]
j'adore et sénateurs n'ont pas que ça
rigole
alors justement on a une on a un truc à
vous dire c'est que c'est sur c'est vite
il ya on est en train de travailler
enfin aujourd'hui qui est en train de
travailler d'ailleurs avec toi
exactement comme coproducteur
voilà du tueur une nouvelle série à
aulas qui va être les nouvelles
nouvelles filles d'à côté
avec sans doute sera très vite on voit
là moi j'ai fait de la figure pour
premier baiser
alors une demi journée j'étais payé 500
francs je me souviens et je jouais une
correspondante italienne eh bien vous
savez une heure à l'image regarda non
attends ils sont plus de cours que nous
on a je suis pas sûr ce sont pour cinq
mois
comme elle est plutôt jolie j'avance en
est tout particulièrement lourd
[Applaudissements]
il ya une année une candidate qui un
candidat a balancé deux sauts de javel
au visage non oui et il a il était sur
le point lui balancer un sceau du rin
pour faire plaisir à son patron pour
aller plus loin et finalement un
caméraman lui arracher ce sont des mains
parce que je pense que l'humain a pris a
pris le dessus sur la production n'a pas
fait il ya de la drogue non oui mon ami
en arial ali haddad la drogue et les
moyens dont il ya de la drogue d'alcool
il ya de la drogue et la production de
sel elle est fournie par la production
elle est fournie par la police moi je
sais pas ce parc par contre j'ai besoin
de comprendre pourquoi vos personne n'a
voulu quitter brutalement la production
n'avez vous fait un super g la tête s'il
ya de la drogue et d'équité on m'a
refusé
mais comment on peut vous refuser sinon
la télé ou trois ans mais en plus à des
histoires peut-être qu'ils ne payent pas
si claouey quitter le tournage mais
quand je vous dis que j'ai insisté
pendant une heure j'ai dit c'est bon je
ne veux plus je veux partir je veux
rentrer chez moi
le nom angèle on a trop beau de besoin
de toi tu es génial tu es super alors
que je tends craint de subir un
acharnement
vous l'avez vu vous l'avez dit on a là
une tentative manifestement raté de
faire une caricature d'une émission vous
avez dit cette enquête et cousinerie
cirad et toute une émission
sensationnaliste même lui en convient
c'est raté
remuez bien sûr la situation on apporte
le marocain c'est vrai qu'ils auraient
été blessés par pas voir cette vidéo ils
ont porté plainte et ils se sont
désistés ce qu'on appelle le thé nadu
d'accord ils ont résisté ce qui
normalement devait éclaircir l'horizon
judiciaire de brahim et sami ça n'a pas
été le cas je vous dis même moi on m'a
appelé je vous dis on a appelé tous ne
m'a appelé aussi pour essayer de que je
puisse joindre le roi du maroc pour lui
demander voilà simon et testa terre
supporters qui claude voilà c'est
quelqu'un qui chez jallet j'ai rencontré
deux fois extrêmement sympathique mais
bon j'ai dit j'ai je vois là je ne peux
pas intervenir là dessus donc les écoles
rouvrent donc je veux que les écoles
rouvrent pourquoi mais parce que moi par
exemple c'est un calvaire qui ont 15 h
des enfants ils ont 5 ans 7 ans 9 ans et
le
mais à huit mois ouais mais comment vous
voulez faire l'école à la maison ça vous
a dit ce n'est pas possible moi jourde
franchement je vous donne les clés de
chez moi
vous venez et vous me dites oh alors
j'ai réussi j'ai fait les donne à fond
salle donner les clés de chez vous à
tout le monde sauf à castanet vidéo
quand vous entendez un cas concret
forcément raison c'est à dire que
forcément voilà moi je suis toujours le
même problème est ce qu'on fait de la
science ou de la pseudo science sur le
même problème
moi je veux bien qu'on ferme les écoles
confirme tout d'ailleurs c'est marrant
il ya un truc qui était marqué sur votre
truc c'est que mi-mai réouverture des
lieux de culte ou quelqu'un lui ducrocq
ministre que les lieux de culte sont
déjà ouverts je vous ai déjà presque
a priori c'est pas allé du culte ont
déjà ouvert raphaël
oui donc vous vous est pris pour cible
dans cette affaire qu'est ce que vous
dites sur le harcèlement dont on a parlé
dans cette émission et que c'est direct
que pour vous c c c c si vous dites
c'est des inepties ou est-ce que vous
ressentez nantes alors cessé d inepties
après du harcèlement c'est un mot qui
est très fort évidemment il ya des
querelles
c'était quoi oui on vous a reproché
d'avoir étranglé une jeune fille et vous
l'aurez reconnu dans une terre alors je
vous explique ça à l'époque c'était ma
compagne j'avais 18 ans je n'ai pas être
anglais et effectivement c'est vrai je
l'approuvé par le coup
d'accord c'est alors c'est pas quelque
chose à faire je vous dis pas maintenant
j'avais 18 ans et je la travaille par le
coup parce qu'elle m'a traitée de d'un
nom d'oiseau d'accord ce devant une
raison non non c'est pas une raison
c'est sûr et certain mais j'avais 18 ans
ça m'est arrivé qu'une seule fois
maintenant je mets au défi n'importe qui
d'autre d'accord de trouver quelque
chose vraiment de jeunes qui regardent
et tout aimé la scène dans une éducation
édition télé réalité vous êtes filmés
mais on peut pas faire rentrer des
stupéfiants mais c'est l'émission et
c'est complètement condamnable mais un
câlin moi j'incite aussi puisque
visiblement on parle de harcèlement mais
on va parler de drogue moi j'incite à
quiconque qui a vécu du harcèlement
d'accord ou qui a vu quelqu'un prendre
de la drogue devant lui allait porter
plainte
il ya un vrai amour est venu j'ai une
question à poser répondez-moi flash est
ce que vous avez déjà vu un candidat
même si ça n'est pas été amené par la
prod prendre de la drogue dans une désir
alors je vais je vais besoin en était
j'ai jamais vu deux candidats prendre de
cocaïne effectivement ça m'est arrivé de
voir un candidat fumer un joint sur le
corps mais d'accord voilà vous en voulez
la vraie vérité
je je je voulais mon desire s
[Musique]